there's a lot of interesting people to
psychoanalyze yeah i'm sure you've saved
a lot of people that try to
psychoanalyze you and go through it
a lot of them
most important person i psychoanalyzes
myself all the time absolutely one time
i sat and i had a list of 83 questions
that was given to me
and
one of the questions was
who knows you the most
why
who do you get along with the most why
who do you not get along the most why
and then
i'm at the beach i'm going through this
question i'm like holy [ __ ]
then you notice a trend like no wonder i
don't get along with people like this
because you remind me of this no wonder
i get along with you because you bring a
certain level of safety no wonder i'm
okay in these types of chaotic
situations because i feel peaceful in
chaotic situations no longer i'm scared
shitless and paranoid when things are
too peaceful because i don't have not
lived in this kind of situation so then
you're like okay now i understand who
you are guy now let me live with you
it's kind of like you're you know
living with yourself so influence of
that over you
what
positive or negative influence you talk
about your dad said women what was it
booze gambling why did you talk about
that we also talk about the positive
influence of that
what positive or negative influence did
mom have over you
yeah so my mother was fantastic she was
an amazing mother
she
i don't know i don't like to talk about
positive and negatives my mother was
very much subservient to my father
which uh was a good thing they used to
have arguments etc
and i think i learned a lot of my
lessons i guess on male female dynamics
to a degree from my childhood like i
remember one time my father was away at
a chess tournament for for a month and a
half he was away for a really long time
he was at chess tournament playing chess
all over the country
came back after a month and a half
within 45 minutes him and my mom are
arguing i think she found something in
his pocket phone number so i don't know
what it was
start arguing he just walked in the
house
and i started arguing today they came
down to me and said son
give me a hug give him a hug goes all
right see in a few weeks it's like where
are you going he goes
when you're older you'll understand your
mother won't shut up
walked out the door i didn't see him
again for two weeks this is who he was
like ah i come home oh you wanna oh
you're a [ __ ] spy that's how he was
as a man right so i learned i did i'm
not saying that i'm that way but i this
is my childhood right i saw it but my
mother was quite subservient to my
father my father was certainly a
disciplinarian who's certainly the man
who's in charge of the house my mother
did her job fantastically she taught us
how to read she she fed us very well she
made sure we ate good
and my dad's basic tenet was your mother
is in charge of keeping you alive
food
go to bed on time eat good go to school
that up she's trying to keep you alive
but i'm in charge of teaching you how to
be a man and conquer the world so we
have different roles so she's going to
keep you alive i'm going to turn up when
i turn up i'm going to teach you some
[ __ ] with you
i'll teach you how to live and they're
different things so they had very clear
defined roles
um to this day my mother she's still
alive i i've retired her completely so
the first thing i did when i got rich
was retiring my mother first thing i did
because my mother was uh when they when
they broke up
so this the sad story of my father which
i've never told but i'll tell it now
my father got uh my father was in the
air force he discharged
after they diagnosed him with
narcissistic personality disorder they
offered him a full military pension six
or seven thousand dollars a month
saying that you know you have this
mental disorder we'll give it to you
because you were such a
fantastic member of the air force my dad
was actually in intelligence some
right-wing people on the internet think
i'm a cia plant because my father was
with intelligence i'm not a cia plant
but my father was an intelligent so when
my father joined the air force he got on
the bus like everyone else did back then
in alabama got on the bus
you go you do an iq test my father did
so good they moved him to intelligence
and my father to this day
held still holds i believe at the time
of his death he still held it the
fastest assimilation of a foreign
language
so back in the 80s and 90s if they
needed someone who speaks russian they'd
train a native
english or american person nowadays you
can get estonian or a latvian because
they're a pro-eu and they speak russian
fluently it's easy back then you need a
russian speaker you'd teach them so they
taught my dad russian he he learned
russian fluently in 15 days head to toe
so he held the fast assimilation of a
russian language and i know that because
when he died i got a message on facebook
metta i got a message on facebook from a
guy who i'd uh never heard of saying hi
you don't know who i am i was in the air
force with your father i heard of his
passing i just want to let you know that
i was in the same place as your father i
was a linguist also for the air force at
the time i was living with a russian
woman and we spoke russian fluently in
the house and your father and i started
classes at the same time and i can say
with certainty the way your father
learned things was was inhuman it was
robotic within three weeks he was
correcting me on my russians
like he was that that's who he was right
so he spoke russian and spanish and
german we were also in berlin at fault
berlin wall so he did a lot of things so
he was a linguist so he used to listen
to the bugs
if they bugged the room he'd listen to
the bug in russian and translate it
um so that's what my father did anyway
when they discharged and they said
narcissistic personality disorder and
the reason they said he had that is
because he refused to listen to one of
his commanders i don't know the exact
story so i don't want to say it on tape
but he refuses what his commanders about
a recording on a tape
and my father was arguing with him about
the translation of a certain word my
father believed it was slang for
something else superior believed it was
something else they got into a personal
beef it developed over months and months
and months of arguments about
translations and eventually and my dad
ended up being told to sleep outside for
eight hours a day and then i got to the
point my father was charged so they
discharged him they diagnosed him a
narcissistic personality disorder he
said he wouldn't listen
and they offered him this military
pension and he refused it
he said my sanity is not for sale
and i know that line because my mother
used to scream all the time when we were
broke in the house you could have had
money emery my sanity is not for sale
now we went broke right so i remember
the bargaining emery we could have had
money now we're broke
so because he became a professional
chess player he couldn't pay the bills
and we were living in indiana and south
south chicago we were looking to get
with no money so i remember him saying
that all the time
so um eventually my mother was it was
english we decided to move back to
england because thing that has social
housing you get free house and you can
get benefits and that kind of thing we
moved back and my father stayed there so
i didn't see my father very much from
the time i moved but my mother was
always in charge of keeping me alive and
he was just in charge of like giving me
the lessons and stuff
so yeah it was an interesting life but
he was he was a super principled man
like he turned down money what was
actually interesting towards the end of
his life
about three or four years before he died
um no no it must have been way before
that because i didn't have money yet
maybe 10 years before he died
he called me and said you know
i've been principled for so long
and the way the world's turning and what
american government's doing
maybe i should have just signed or do
you think i should have just signed
didn't say maybe [ __ ] do you think i
should have just signed i said no dad no
you get to live with a pure heart you
shouldn't have just signed your mother
saying
i should just sign it now and cause i
get back
sign what exactly sign the narcissistic
personality disorder sell his sanity and
get back paid which at the time would be
like half a million dollars
by the way just so you know a lot of
people slammed it
a lot a lot of military i mean you know
people who got a you signed you get all
this incredible pension back pay
and why do they want you to sign this
why they want his father to sign this
they want the sonic is even its fault
it's all your fault you're wrong about
everything you're psycho your sanity is
for sale you saw yourself five thousand
dollars a month
so he found out that he could get back
paid he signed it
so he had a long conversation with me
and i said look dad i think you did the
right thing i'm so proud of you we
talked back and forth and said you know
what your mother this is the time you
have money your mother is a dinner lady
my mother was a dinner lady at this
point after we moved to england we had
some things but she was a dinner lady
she got like 400 a month for cleaning
plates she had arthritis she was
starting to get bad knee from standing
up all day
because you know i'm not even with her
anymore she calls me so many headaches
but i can't let her just wash dishes son
i might just sign it i was like well dad
the choice is yours my dad agreed he
goes look i'm running out of time anyway
i'm running out of life i've taught i
taught you boys a lesson you know what
that he went to sign he went to the
military to try and sign it for the back
pay that declined him
he said ah you're not crazy anymore
no i wouldn't give him money funny that
so let's talk about that's another story
so when he died
uh when he died i still didn't have that
much money but then after he died about
luckily i started to make money by a
year two years later and because he
tried to retire my mother obviously i
also have an own debt to my mother the
first thing i did when i made money was
retirement so i'd say to this day about
15 to 20 of my income goes to my mother
she has panic attacks like she'll check
her bank and be like
this is too much money i can't buy it
she doesn't she's like scared of me like
just buy lambo chill it's fine if you
enjoyed this video and you want to watch
the entire podcast click over here and
if you want to be connected with experts
influencers such as kiyosaki tate
connolly parliamentary myself and others
download the app minect where you get a
chance to connect with these folks by
the minute you get to buy the minute or
have face times with them 15 minutes ask
them any questions you may want to have
download the app connect and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
[Music]